no man's sky is an exploration games set
in a vast galaxy of over 18 quintillion
planets this is a game about travel
survival and commerce backed by
impressive tech that allows for near
seamless transitions from ground to
space
every facet contains multiple layers to
consider while some details will make
your journey feel more genuine than most
there are flaws that occasionally get in
the way of your investment in the
Odyssey however there's an intriguing
narrative that puts new context on your
in-game actions making for a fascinating
experience that ultimately trumps issues
that appear early on
most of the things you see and interact
with during your journey have been
arranged by an algorithm the sheer
number of variation of world and
inhabiting species is too large to fully
comprehend but because the variety is
defined by a computer pulling from a
restricted pool of options animals
appear more like slapdash creations than
thoughtful constructions you will spend
hours whittling away at rocks plants and
asteroids in search of commodities using
your multi-tool on the ground or your
ship's weapon in space as you explore
you have to monitor your exosuit
equipment to maintain protection from
hazardous conditions and occasionally to
recover from violent encounters combat
is a secondary activity however but it
occurs often enough to make the games
unrefined multi-tool controls a standout
issue aiming the weapon component of
your multi-tool is finicky enough to
make these encounters more of an
annoyance than an enjoyable challenge
battles with space pirates lack
excitement in-depth offering simple
visual targets that you fire into as
enemies storm from afar and little else
to consider
your starship and exosuit have a limited
number of slots that can hold stacks of
resources or we use to apply equipment
upgrades so you try to be efficient and
work with what you have but no man's sky
doesn't make this easy you have to
navigate a plane grid of items using a
slow moving cursor holding down a button
for seconds at a time to confirm every
action managing your inventory is a
large part of no man's sky so this
becomes a regular annoyance in space
stations and outpost strewn across
planets even counter friendly NPCs that
are open to trade at first these
encounters offer temporary relief from
prolonged isolation but interactions are
largely devoid of meaning at best you
can learn bits of each species lexicon
by discovering translation monoliths but
even this process lacks substantial
meaning as translations reveal truly
stiff and impersonal dialogue the
starships you find come in a range of
models with varying color palettes and
accessories and while you may get lucky
and find a wrecked but improved ship to
repair and call your own ships are
readily available in Space Station
hangars where traders come and go in
real time in a galaxy with no real
friends or social ties it's easy to look
at possessions as a way to curb
loneliness and provide meaning to your
journey as time goes on however you may
lose the high that comes from your new
purchase and seek another a cycle that
continues and grows increasingly
draining if you adhere to the direct
path towards the center of the galaxy in
pursuit of the game's primary goal no
man's sky grows tiresome in less time
than a game with this much potential
ought to no matter how many solar
systems you jump to or planets you
explore you will likely grow tired of
repetitive NPC interactions and planets
implied but shallow variety you'll also
lose interest in new ships perhaps the
journey altogether however tucked neatly
into the galaxy is a narrative path
delivered so subtly that you may miss
the fact that the first decision you
make in the game activating a distress
beacon connects you to a mysterious
force known as Atlas as you continue to
travel the Stars you encounter
individuals that will steer you towards
Atlas stations fast temple-like spaces
with altars that allow you to convene
with the spirit of Atlas at first what
Atlas is can be difficult to pin down
but if you continue to heat its call it
will open your eyes to the greater
truths about you your journey and the
galaxy the realizations that Atlas stirs
in your character's mind address big
picture
questions pertaining to not only the
game but life itself it forced me to
confront the point of my wandering the
value of material wealth and the reason
for existence atlas in many ways
illustrates the value religion plays in
some people's lives but it also quite
cleverly examines the role a game like
no man's sky plays in our personal
fulfillment when I was on the brink of
disillusionment Atlas renewed my spirit
and fueled my desire to press onward in
search of a greater meaning
no man's sky is immediately a massive
game and it will entertain the inter
collector in you for a while the more
you get to know it the more you
recognize its faults but if you consider
everything it has to offer no man's sky
becomes more than a collection of
slightly different worlds at a seemingly
never-ending galaxy it becomes an
examination of the meaning of life in a
way that's more valuable than all the
gold or starships in the galaxy